I want the truth
who this guy really is.
We have tried everything.
You were the only one who gave us hope.
I will try my best.
I’ve been trying to get an angle on this
medical piece.
Paolo Macchiarini
who’s developing artificial organs.
Medical miracles.
The work I do, this could change the world.
I take a 3D-printed trachea
and transform it into a living organ.
This is groundbreaking work.
The implications are historic.
Perhaps...
he’ll even bring the Nobel home.
I’m producing a special about you.
Your patients,
they really trust you.
Do you trust me?
Where is he?
Just sicker than any of us expected.
He wasn’t!
Why are you not holding him accountable?
The issues are completely unrelated
to my procedure.
You’ve always had great instincts.
Maybe you should trust them.
I need you to look into someone for me.
He’s experimenting on people.
I want to see it with my own eyes.
My team and I have to deal with
very extreme cases.
Just the ones extreme enough that
nobody will notice when you kill them.
History is built on lines
that we must be willing to cross.
What’d you do, Paolo?
What did you do to them?
We have to figure out a way to stop this guy.
She’s sitting there with a
bloody time bomb in her throat.
Clear!
Welcome back.